trump gets a special master it's the
most beautiful special master anyone has
ever seen it's the most special the most
wonderful special master that has ever
existed uh he's not wrong people have
never seen a special master like this
but what does that all mean well a
florida federal judge eileen cannon has
temporarily halted the criminal
investigators from reviewing the records
found in mar-a-lago and ordered the
appointment of a special master to check
the government's work however the judge
also allowed the government's
intelligence damage assessment to
continue many lawyers were quick to
condemn the judge's ruling i think the
driver on this from the beginning was it
was you know loads of classified
information sitting in mar-a-lago people
say this was unprecedented well it's
also unprecedented for a president to
take all this classified information and
put them in a country club why are they
right to be upset well before we set our
hair on fire let's look at how we got
here and then consider what the judge
ruled and why and of course why the doj
is going to appeal that order to the
11th circuit and what that means
[Music]
now all this got off to a strange start
when trump's lawyers didn't file this
motion
in the court that had created the search
warrant in the first place instead they
created a new case a civil case and that
landed in front of federal judge eileen
cannon who we'll talk about in a moment
now in the doj's brief in opposition to
an appointment of a special master it
outlined new details about the
classified documents that trump had
taken from the white house first it
included a photograph of the materials
displayed on the floor of mar-a-lago the
photo shows five yellow folders marked
top secret and a red one labeled secret
lying on the ground beside a box of
magazine covers now the photo is pretty
standard procedure by law enforcement
they normally document the things that
they have seized now trump and his
lawyers were outraged by the photo which
they say merely shows that trump was in
possession of his own records but also
their response did not address one of
the key claims that trump supporters
continue to make that trump declassified
everything in their possession
so far the lawyers have not bothered to
make this argument in front of a court
but donald trump was very offended by
this photograph for other reasons he
called up a conservative radio show to
rant about how sloppy the fbi was with
the records he claimed he kept them in a
much neater fashion but i had
confidential documents spread out all
over my far floor
and uh like a slob trump's family
members also emphasized the former
president wasn't need free quote he's a
very neat individual he would never
scatter documents around on a floor like
that but none of this is about whether
trump is a slob the issue is whether
trump had possession of documents that
he was not allowed to possess in a
completely unsecured location trump's
comments could also be viewed as an
admission that those records were not
planted by the fbi which is contrary to
some of the other messaging that the
trump camp has been doing the justice
department's filing also pushed back on
trump's claim that he'd been cooperating
with government all along the doj said
that when they arrived at mar-a-lago on
june 3 one of trump's lawyers handed
over a single redwelt envelope double
wrapped in tape the lawyer said that the
records inside had come from a storage
room another lawyer probably christina
bob signed a certification letter
swearing under oath that a diligent
search had been conducted and that all
the classified materials on the property
had been turned over or all the
documents that had been labeled as
classified
side note elena habba and christina bob
trump's lawyers
have given several interviews where they
potentially incriminated themselves as
witnesses or targets of the criminal
investigation
um sorry to interrupt but was there was
there a limited number of people who had
access to that storage room it seems
like a pretty important room right since
they've made such a big deal of it and
have the lock on it and so forth so were
there a limited number of people who
could go in and out
yes or have access to mar-a-lago
certainly mar-a-lago is secure in and of
itself you know just getting on to the
compound is hard and then it was a
locked door and getting you know back
down into the basement there's security
you can't just walk down there only
certain members of staff can get there
and then there's only one key they found
these three mundane statues espionage
and the two others obstruction
ahaba told charlie kirk that on may 5th
2022 she searched all desks drawers
nightstands dressers closets etc with
explicit permission from trump in an
effort to track down documents related
to a subpoena from new york attorney
general leticia james investigation into
the trump organization and although the
new york investigation is a separate
matter habba placed herself at the scene
of the potential crime and when the
justice department delegation asked to
see the storage room a lawyer for trump
explicitly prohibited them from opening
or looking into any of the other boxes
inside the government asserted that this
stopped them from confirming that no
materials with classification markings
had been left behind
investigators then discovered evidence
that there were still classified
documents at mar-a-lago and this
probably came from witness interviews
and after further investigation the doj
team said it had reason to believe that
government records had likely been quote
concealed and removed from the storage
room and that efforts may have been
taken to obstruct the government's
investigation then the government
decided to apply for a search warrant in
the filing the government said that when
they went inside mar-a-lago agents found
more than twice the number of classified
documents that trump's lawyers had
handed over before when they allegedly
had made their diligent search back in
june including three that were found not
in the storage room but in desks in the
former president's office now the doj's
brief also included two grand jury
subpoenas the first subpoena asked trump
to turn over the documents at mar-a-lago
and the second was for footage from
surveillance cameras
mar-a-lago footage would be used to
track the movement of the materials
within the club now i'm largely going to
skip over the trump reply brief in
response to the doj's opposition it's
less of a legal document and more of
just a public relations attempt it
really doesn't address any of the things
that the judge wanted them to address it
fails to rebut any of the arguments
that the doj has put forward and
similarly as we covered before the judge
teed up exactly the issues that she
wanted the trump team to address and
they failed to address those issues in
either the moving papers for the special
master or in the reply brief effectively
their papers were just placeholders just
getting something in front of the judge
though as we now know that's all they
needed to do as i alluded to earlier the
judge has now ruled in trump's favor on
the motion to appoint a special master
the order appointing a special master
was issued by district court judge
eileen cannon who it's important to note
was nominated by trump to the bench in
2020. judge cannon was confirmed by the
senate by a vote of 56-21 just days
after trump lost the november 2020
election so first things first is it
kosher for a judge to rule on a criminal
matter involving the president who
appointed them well there's absolutely
no law saying that they can't generally
it's not a conflict of interest for
judges to rule on matters involving the
president who appointed them this
happens fairly regularly but that
typically comes up in the context of
laws that the president enacts or
executive orders that they issue not in
actual criminal matters uh that concern
that particular president all right so
with that out of the way let's look at
what the judge actually did the first
issue is the judge's order on rule 41g
trump filed a motion seeking the return
of privileged materials and property
under federal rule of criminal procedure
41g that rule allows a person quote
aggrieved by an unlawful search and
seizure of property or by the
deprivation of property to move for the
property's return now since there's no
pending criminal case trump filed a
motion as a plaintiff in a civil case
that means he was trying to initiate an
action in the pre-indictment stage now
in the case of richie versus smith the
fifth circuit court of appeals developed
a four-part test to determine whether
the government must return property in a
pre-indictment case first whether the
motion for return of property accurately
alleges the government agents displayed
a callous disregard for the rights of
the plaintiff second whether the
plaintiff has an individual interest in
and need for the material whose return
he seeks third whether the plaintiff
would be irreparably injured by the
denial of the return of the property and
fourth whether the plaintiff has an
adequate remedy law for the redress of
his grievance now the rationale the
ritchie case is that the government
should not be allowed to seize and
retain privileged documents in a
pre-indictment setting however quote in
order for an owner of property to invoke
rule 41g he must show that he had a
possessory interest in the property
seized by the government now the doj had
argued that trump cannot show he had a
right to the records that were seized
citing the presidential records act
which says that presidential records are
owned by the united states not by the
former president and during oral
argument on the motion the judge asked
trump's lawyer to address the second and
third ritchie factors lawyer jim trustee
trump's lawyer replied that the entire
dispute was akin to an argument over
overdue library books now the judge
described trump's motion as quote
somewhat convoluted but concluded that
quote this filing is procedurally
permissible and creates an action in
equity though there has been a lot of
pushback about the court's jurisdiction
in this particular case and in assessing
the richie factors the judge said that
the doj did not display khalsa's regard
for trump's rights so the government
came out ahead on the first factor but
it was all downhill from there as to the
second factor whether trump has an
individual interest in and need for the
material seized the judge said that this
factor cut in trump's favor since the
doj by its own admission had seized
trump's medical records correspondence
related to taxes and financial
information judge cannon says that this
amounts to over 500 pages of documents
however the government seized over 11
000 documents which means that the
subset of documents that belongs to
trump amounts to less than five percent
of the records seized under the warrant
the doj argued that the mixing of these
personal items with other documents is
evidence of a crime and can have
evidentiary value in and of itself if
trump stored his personal records with
classified materials and post-it notes
it could suggest something about his
men's rea his mental state for what he
was doing with these classified or
protected documents now judge cannon is
a former federal prosecutor and she
agreed that the justice department's
concern was valid but she said that
trump's interest was stronger and the
third factor is irreparable harm to show
irreparable harm a plaintiff needs to
demonstrate that there would be no
remedy for the damage that the
government inflicted the judge concluded
that a special master was necessary to
stop harm to trump's reputation leaks to
the press could be harmful to trump and
the judge concluded with no analysis
that the government leaked stories to
the press although the government
obviously denied this and she seemed to
ignore the fact that it was former
president trump who was providing almost
all of the information to the press when
these things happened in real time now
judge cannon said that trump could be
irreparably harmed because of the stigma
of potential criminal
prosecution quote frequently the public
remembers the accusation and still
suspects guilt even after an acquittal
though as many criminal defense lawyers
have pointed out including ronaldo
mariotti mark zaid and sarah azari uh
all defendants suffer reputational
damage when they are indicted um
not just this former president these
lawyers also said that they were looking
forward to citing this case on behalf of
their clients
and yes it would be good for criminal
defendants if they could have a special
master to review evidence uh seized from
them in the pre-indictment stage in all
criminal cases and they would have a
much better chance of avoiding criminal
indictment if they could identify the
government's witnesses and knew what the
government was thinking beforehand and
that's one of the reasons why the doj
opposed trump's motion for a special
master but national security lawyer
bradley moss thinks that it won't help
most criminal defendants because the
judge wrote this to help trump and trump
only now in her order judge cannon seems
to confirm moss's conclusion that the
rules are different in this particular
case quote as a function of plaintiff's
former position as president of the
united states the stigma associated with
the subject seizure is in a league of
its own and judge cannon came up with
another reason why trump might suffer
irreparable harm quote a future
indictment based to any degree on
property that ought to be returned would
result in reputational harm of a
decidedly different order of magnitude
of course we aren't there yet trump has
not been indicted much less indicted
because of personal property that the
fbi had no right to seize uh that and as
many have pointed out often you are
allowed to seize documents that are
intermingled with the uh the documents
that are explicitly mentioned in a
search warrant but the judge suggests
that trump wouldn't have any remedy or
any defense if he was indicted based on
material the government should not have
seized but that's incorrect if trump is
indicted using evidence that the
government should not have taken his
lawyers would file a motion to suppress
the evidence but judge cannon heads this
off and argues that a special master can
prevent this from happening by checking
the government's work in the first place
now all of this seems to contradict the
judge's same decision to allow the
intelligence community through the odni
to continue its review of the evidence
while the criminal investigation has to
stop
here the odni is uh doing its damage
assessment to find out who had access to
the sensitive information in the
documents and whether national security
interests were compromised and i suppose
someone could argue that the criminal
investigation
into trump's records would harm his
reputation while the intelligence
community investigation would not but
that seems incredibly dubious not to
mention it's all part of the same
executive branch which many have argued
is a unitary executive branch and on top
of that the intelligence review could
lead to further criminal charges
moreover some people have already
concluded that trump put human
intelligence sources at risk that
conclusion if it's mistaken
would seem to be just as serious as the
stigma that attaches to a criminal
investigation itself now the doj filed
an extensive brief explaining how its
filter team separates personal items and
attorney client privileged records from
everything else that the doj sees the
judge was unmoved by their arguments
however she held that
trump met the four ritchie factors the
judge said that rating the ex-president
without a third-party reviewer just
doesn't look good quote the government's
argument that another round of initial
screening is unnecessary also disregards
the value added by an outside reviewer
in terms of at a minimum the appearance
of fairness even if the doj filter
review teams often pass procedural
muster they're not always perceived to
be as impartial as special masters and
that takes us to the judge's analysis of
the executive privilege issue which is
to put it mildly convoluted judge cannon
says the government made a mistake by
not screening the records for executive
privilege now this overlooks the fact
that justice department is part of the
executive branch and that president
biden holds the executive privilege now
and has already delegated his authority
to nara which says none of these
documents can be protected by trump
under the guise of executive privilege
but this order hints that this is really
a dispute between former president trump
and current president biden the supreme
court's president says that executive
privilege
almost under every circumstance stays
with the office of the current president
it's theoretically possible under the
nixon versus gsa case for a former
president to have some tiny sliver of
executive privilege but
that's never happened so far and the
circumstances in which that could
theoretically happen uh are extremely
circumscribed but the judge says that a
special master must review all the
government records to determine if trump
can raise executive privilege to shield
these records but so far the judge has
only raised this issue we don't know
what procedures if any the special
master will have to follow when one is
appointed so let's talk about what it
means to appoint a special master
normally a special master would help the
court sift through materials that may be
subject to attorney-client privilege
now someone is going to screen these
records for attorney-client privilege
and presumably executive privilege but
that's sort of up in the air federal
courts haven't developed case law about
when an ex-president can
assert executive privilege so the
special master is not going to have any
guidance based on the case law itself
but presumably we'll get more guidance
from the court when it issues its final
order actually appointing the special
master and there is another complication
that goes unaddressed by the judge here
the the pra requires a dispute over
presidential records to be handled in
the u.s district court in washington d.c
44 usc section 2204 states quote the
united states district court for the
district of columbia shall have
jurisdiction over any action initiated
by the former president asserting that a
determination made by the archivist
violates the former president's
constitutional rights or privileges
here judge cannon in her order said she
recognizes that this is the law of the
pra but she doesn't say how the special
masters appointment can be squared with
section 2204. if she admits that section
2204 applies then why would a special
master appointed in the southern
district of florida have any power why
does her particular civil court case
have any power in the southern district
of florida so what happens next well now
the parties must meet and confer about
who might serve as a special master
ideally they would agree on a list of
names but that's almost certainly not
going to happen here keep in mind that
this order only applies to evidence
seized on august 8th it actually doesn't
apply to an earlier subset of documents
that trump sent to nara or the boxes of
records that his lawyers gave to the new
york city d.a alvin bragg and while many
attorneys have rightfully criticized
judge cannon's order here we'll really
get a window into whether she's just
trying to bend over backwards to provide
fairness to a former president in a
politically charged atmosphere or
whether she's in the bag for trump based
on who she appoints as the special
master and on thursday the department of
justice officially filed a notice of
appeal with judge cannon and a motion
for partial stay of her order regarding
the special master pending that appeal
now the notice of appeal is just a
placeholder it's just a paragraph that
you file with a court that says they
will appeal the september 5th special
master order and the injunction but the
motion for partial stay has more detail
the government quote seeks to stay to
the extent the order enjoins the further
review and use for criminal
investigative purposes of records
bearing classification markings that
were recovered pursuant to a court
authorized search warrant and requires
the government to disclose those
classified records to a special master
for review now the doj says that it
disagrees with the court's decision to
appoint a special master over the
materials but it's only seeking an
immediate relief over a subset of those
records the ones marked classified
because those aspects of the order will
cause the most immediate and serious
harms to the government and the public
the classified records a discrete set of
just over 100 documents have already
been segregated from the other seized
records and are being maintained
separately now the department of justice
argues the classified records are also
not personal to the plaintiff
former president trump and would not
reveal any sensitive personal
information the justice department took
issue with the judge's conclusion that
as of right now it isn't possible to
determine which records trump might own
saying that the classified government
records are easily identifiable by their
markings
are already segregated
from the other c's records and do not
include personal records or potentially
privileged communications with his
personal attorneys in other words the
doj has already done its review the
government disagreed as expected with
the judge's interpretation of executive
privilege and the nixon versus gsa case
and the doj has a bone to pick with
judge canada over her reliance on a
concurrence by justice kavanaugh in the
case of trump versus thompson the doj
argued thompson involved a claim of
executive privilege by a plaintiff as to
record sought by a congressional
committee which means that he wanted to
stop dissemination of the privileged
materials outside of the executive
branch and that makes a little bit of
sense in the possible theoretical places
where a former president could
exert executive privilege it would
probably be against a third party not
the executive branch itself and the doj
argued that quote neither the supreme
court's opinion and kavanaugh's
concurring statement concluded that an
ex-president can successfully assert
executive privilege to prevent the
executive branch itself from reviewing
and using its own records the doj also
argued it didn't make any sense that
part of the executive branch could
continue its review and part of the
executive branch could not but this
appeal is a risky move it could lead to
a delay that could take longer than
complying with a special master
procedures and they could also lose the
appeal because the 11th circuit is going
to 11th circuit and generate unfavorable
precedent and in a minute order the
court asked both parties to respond to
the doj's motion and it gave trump until
september 12th to file his response now
some see this as the beginning of the
judge walking back from her extreme
position before getting hammered on
appeal
but she may also just be crossing t's
and dotting eyes but you'll be able to
read all about trump's circumvention of
all rational laws in today's sponsor
morning brew because that's my favorite
way to catch up with pop culture and the
news i've actually been subscribed to
morningbrew for forever it's one of my
absolute favorite newsletters and i'm
really thrilled to tell you why because
morningbrew if you didn't already know
it's a free daily newsletter delivered
monday through sunday it gets you up to
speed on business finance tech and law
in just five minutes it provides a
fantastic quick summary of the most
important issues all while being witty
irreverent informative and fun and did i
mention it's completely free this week i
read all about the passing of the queen
the uk's new prime minister nasa's new
space launch artemis missouri bringing
back spanking to its schools and someone
who sailed 40 miles in an 861 pound
pumpkin it's basically exactly the mix
of news that i'm actually interested in
and the stuff that i'd even know i
wanted to know about and it's all
written in a hilarious style morning
brew is one of the few emails that i
actually open every single day so legal
eagles this one is a complete no-brainer
morning brew is completely free and it
takes less than 15 seconds to subscribe
just click on the link that's on screen
right now or in the description to get
morningbrew for free and not only will
you get a newsletter that you'll
actually read you'll actually help out
this channel too so click on the link
below to get morningbrew right away and
after that click on this link over here
for more illegal eagle or i'll see you
in court